a new survey shows Millennials are poor
lonely depressed and socialist we
analyze why young Americans are so
miserable then Apple CEO Tim Cook gives
Tulane graduates terrible advice and
from the u.s. to the UK leftists or
becoming violent and threatening our
political system we will examine it I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show before we get into that
there's a new poll that just came out on
the question of illegal immigration and
I think it's a pretty telling poll it
shows that after three years now of
Democrats and the left trying to move
public opinion on the question of
immigration demonizing those of us who
want to build a wall and enforce our
border as some sort of awful bigoted
terrible hateful people even after all
of that the whole mainstream media honed
in on this issue of immigration for
three years two-thirds of Americans
oppose releasing illegal aliens into the
United States while they wait for their
asylum hearings two-thirds still want to
keep the illegal aliens incarcerated
until they can be deported or they
receive their Asylum and further 68
percent of Americans want to send those
illegal aliens back to Mexico ASAP
that's from Harvard Harris I think this
shows the durability of the immigration
issue obviously we don't have the wall
yet it's unclear whether the Trump
campaign is going to be campaigning
primarily on immigration or not so we
want to know what you feel about this we
want to know should President Trump
build the wall now before re-election
get it going into 2020 or should he give
in to the political pressure and back
off the immigration issue completely you
know to try to win those mythical
suburban voters that all the squishes
are are concerned about I think you know
how I feel about this question we want
to know what you think just go to Daley
wire poll comm and answer a few
questions this will help us better
understand where you are coming from
also admit it admit it you think that
cyber crime is something that happens to
other people
to you though nobody wants your data
hackers could never grab your passwords
or credit card details well you would be
wrong
stealing data from unsuspecting people
on public Wi-Fi is one of these simplest
and cheapest ways for hackers to make
money and you have a lot of data on your
computer you've got a lot of credit card
numbers you've got all those websites
those weird websites that you've been
looking at I'm talking of course about
the Daily wire calm when you leave your
internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your passwords
and credit card numbers on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see to protect myself from cyber
criminals I use Express VPN expressvpn
is very simple it secures and anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public IP
address you might be thinking oh I'm not
that technologically savvy I don't need
that you need it all of your data are
out there for everyone to see
expressvpn runs seamlessly in the
background of your computer phone or
tablet turning it on takes just one
click using expressvpn you can surf
safely on public Wi-Fi without being
snooped on or having your personal data
stolen all of that is less than seven
bucks a month that's like two cups of
coffee do it you will not regret it your
only regret it when someone steals your
information it's easy to prevent but
you've got to go to expressvpn the
number one VPN service by tech radar and
comes with a money 30-day money-back
guarantee protect your online activity
today find out how you can get three
months free at expressvpn comm slash
michael expr ESS VPN comm slash michael
for three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn comm / michael
mi CH AE l to learn more millenials are
not growing up this obviously we see
this in our own meandering through life
this is also being born out according to
surveys and data Millennials are not
kids anymore I know they think they're
kids I know they all think they're young
and fresh faces but Millennials are
actually now approaching middle-age the
oldest Millennials are 38 years old
right now and they are staring down
middle-age in worse financial shape than
Jen's
Gen X or their parents the baby boomers
they are looking down middle-age
actually in worse shape than every
living Generation
ahead of them why is this now what the
Millennials will do is they'll blame the
financial crisis in the recession
fair enough a lot of Millennials
graduated during an economic downturn
this does have negative effects on your
earning potential for the rest of your
life however we've also now experienced
a full decade of economic growth and
falling unemployment I mean we have
millions of jobs right now that are
going unfilled because there aren't
enough people who are looking for the
jobs we have virtually no unemployment
at 49 year lows and the economy is going
gangbusters
we've had a huge bull run the market is
doing great also by the way during the
recession and the economic downturn the
baby boomers were entering their 19th
they're entering their 50s so they were
entering into their prime earning years
during that downturn so it hurt them as
well everyone has had to suffer and yet
Millennials have less money less
property lower marriage rates and fewer
children they are not doing the things
that adults are supposed to do as they
grow up just as an example the average
household net worth of Millennials is 92
thousand dollars that is 40 percent less
than what Gen X had at the same age and
20 percent less than what baby boomers
had at the same age and baby boomers
were hippie-dippie flower children yeah
I would can't believe they would have
any money and yet Millennials somehow
have even less the only area where
Millennials are outperforming the people
who came before us is in education and
even that is fake so the one area
according to all these social surveys
where Millennials are doing better than
other generations is in education and
the reason they come to that conclusion
is they say well see X percentage of
Millennials went to college X percent of
Millennials went to a four-year college
X percent of Millennials got a master's
degree or a PhD so on the surface it
looks like Millennials are better
educated except we know they're not
better educated because we've talked to
them and we have eyes and ears so we
know just a few little statistics a
third of American Millennials believe
that George W Bush killed more people
than Joseph Stalin 2/3 of Millennials
have never heard of Auschwitz the about
50 percent of Millennials believe there
are more than two biological sexes in
really demonstrable ways they are not
educated at all we know there was a
survey from the Intercollegiate Studies
Institute that tracked students at some
of the top colleges in the country they
found out that seniors graduating from
Berkeley Stanford Yale Columbia all
these high falutin schools seniors who
were graduating knew less about their
nation's history system of government
and civics then incoming freshmen they
had actually gotten stupider during
their time in college so they have a lot
of degrees but they don't know very much
even that one area where they're
supposed to excel they don't however
what did they get for all of their
degrees a ton of student debt so the one
area in education where they are
actually outperforming other generations
is they have a lot more debt they paid a
lot more to get a lot less the average
student loan balance for Millennials is
10 $1,600 and some people obviously have
a lot more than that
some people have zero but that average
is twice what gen-x owed at our age the
generation that came right before us had
half the student debt on average that we
do so as a result of all of this turmoil
as you might expect
Millennials are miserable again not just
subjectively objectively we can see they
are miserable you can see this in
depression rates you can see this in
rates of stress and anxiety the New York
Times like a broken clock right twice a
day dubbed Millennials the
antidepressant generation right now one
in six Americans is hooked on anti
depression drugs this includes one in 20
teenagers Millennials are hooked on
these drugs and are getting these
diagnoses at twice the national average
diagnosis of anxiety depression so
they're they're miserable they're
clinically miserable they're being
diagnosed as misery
why why is it who is to blame for this
or what is to blame for this
a lot of pandering politicians are going
around and they're blaming everything
but the Millennials and this is
especially true as Millennials become
the politicians so alexandria casio
cortez for instance blames the sun
monster for everybody's problems and she
just sort of whines and complains and I
mean aoc the Millennial par excellence
you see Eric's well well doing this Pete
Budaj edge to a lesser degree does this
they blame economic downturns they blame
the recession they blame the system they
blame white men they blame the
patriarchy they blame everything but
themselves they blame capitalism they've
now convinced Millennials to support
socialism for the first time ever the
majority of Millennials majority of that
generation supports socialism over
capitalism those are all the external
forces some baby boomers our parents are
blaming themselves for this everyone's
taking blame I think the misery is
mostly Millennials fault I'm looking at
that man in the mirror I'm asking him to
change his ways taking a little personal
responsibility I think most millennial
misery is not to blame on economic
cycles or politicians or the Sun monster
but you global warming or any of those
things I think it's because of what we
ourselves are doing and that was just my
hunch it turns out I'm correct Deloitte
has come out with its global millennial
survey can you imagine how awful that
survey must have been to administer just
talking to 13,000 Millennials from 42
different countries it looked also it's
a little over 3,000 members of Gen Z and
it it identified personal behaviors that
young Americans and young people around
the world are engaging in that clearly
are causing them not to grow up it's
causing them to live in Neverland and
it's and as a result of that it's
causing them to be miserable we will get
to that in one second but first purple
mattress makes me feel so so good and it
will feel different to you than anything
you've ever
variance because purple uses a brand-new
material that was developed by an actual
rocket scientist and this is not someone
who majored in lesbian dance studies in
college he majored in rocket science and
then made this wonderful mattress it's
not like memory foam it's not like an
inner spring purple feels unique because
it is firm and soft at the same time how
is that possible I don't know I'm not a
rocket scientist but it is it feels
great it keeps everything supported
while still feeling really comfortable
and it's breathable so it sleeps cool
you won't just get super hot while
you're sleeping on it it gives you this
kind of zero-gravity feel it's just
great I actually can't articulate how
great it feels because you just have to
try it to believe it but it's amazing
when I go on the road which I do a lot I
have to sleep on regular mattresses and
I don't sleep it's just not nearly as
nice you can get a 100 night risk-free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund it's backed by ten year warranty
free shipping and returns free in-home
setup and old mattress removal you will
love purple I promise you it is awesome
right now my listeners will get a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress that's in addition to the great
free gifts they're offering site-wide
just text knowles
KO wles to eight four eight eight eight
the only way to get this free pillow is
to text knowles eight four two eight
four eight eight eight k n o wles
two eight four eight eight eight do it
now get a free pillow message and data
rates may apply Deloitte came out with
the global millennial survey and I don't
think they did the survey to figure out
why Millennials are children and why
Millennials are miserable but they
identified a lot of behaviors that
explain it so just fifty percent of
Millennials and Gen Z's aspire to
purchase a home they don't want to own a
home even fewer Millennials and Gen Z's
aspire to start a family do you know
what the majority of Millennials and Gen
zere's want to do fifty seven percent
they just want to see the world man they
just you know they just want to collect
experiences I don't need stuff I just
need
experiences and I hear this all the time
from my friends they say who cares about
owning stuff and settling down I just
kind of want to be on the road do my own
thing you know I'm like Jack Kerouac on
the road and puff puff pass it on in a
certain sense I think people admire this
attitude because you're saying oh yeah
you don't care about material
possessions you don't care about this
stuff that'll just pass away I mean the
my desk
even this leftist here's tumblr
eventually after seven thousand years
will disintegrate and pass away but
memories they won't pass away
experiences they won't pass away however
what this ultimately means is an
epidemic of selfishness you collect
experiences because they're just
personally satisfying and they're cheap
and you don't have to build anything and
you don't have to get a stake in
anything when you purchase a home you
are saying this is my land I'm gonna
keep up this house I'm gonna fix it if
the roof leaks I am gonna pay for the
new oil burner if the oil burner breaks
I am gonna fill this house with kids and
with furniture and with other stuff that
I'm gonna have to buy I'm gonna take out
a mortgage that I'm gonna have to pay
off am I gonna pay it off I'm gonna work
why am I gonna work am I gonna work
because it's personally satisfying all
the time no hopefully sometimes it'll be
personally satisfying a lot of times
it'll be a job but I'll do it because I
have accountability to my creditors who
I took the mortgage ad from and to my
wife and to my kids and I'm gonna have
responsibility and I don't just get to
go out and travel the world whenever I
want to I have to settle down into some
duty that's what I think it is I don't
think that it's just about money
the the defenders of the millennial view
the ones who say I just want to go out
and collect experiences and see the
world they say look people graduated
with a lot of student debt they
graduated in a bad economy and so they
can't afford to buy a house okay maybe
that's true but if you can't afford to
buy a house how can you afford to travel
all over the world world travel is not
cheap it's very expensive and world
travel is extra expensive because if you
actually want to go around the world for
a couple months
you
can't work so it's SuperDuper expensive
and I think what it boils down to
ultimately is responsibility versus
selfishness and self-indulgence now I
have more evidence for this from the
Deloitte survey
according to the global millennial
survey 52% of Millennials said that
earning a high salary was a top priority
52% 48% of Millennials don't care about
earning a high salary why not
again the charitable view is well we're
just not attached to stuff we don't need
your corporate structure man we don't
need all that stuff
the I think more realistic view is
Millennials are kind of lazy what if
it's it's just socialism right I mean if
your why would you work hard if you're
not going to get that much more out of
it what you say okay I'm I'm perfectly
willing to settle for an okay salary if
I don't have to work hard the people who
build things the people who do great
things the people who really succeed at
the top they all work super duper hard
they're not willing to settle in terms
of money if they make a hundred thousand
dollars a year they want to make a
million dollars a year some people if
they make a hundred thousand dollars a
year they say okay cool I'm going to
only work this hard for the rest of my
life that's good 100 grand great but
people who really build things who work
really hard they'll say no I want more
even if they don't get more a hundred
thousand dollars is a great salary they
say no I'm gonna work even harder the
people that I've met who are really
succeeding at the top of their game the
ones who have made a ton of money or
have gotten super famous or have been
really effective in politics the one
thing I notice about all of them is they
are working all the time they're
workhorses I think there's this myth
that a lot of Millennials have bought
into because they bought into socialism
which is that the guys at the top are
all lazy fat cats who just sit at their
desk and they have their feet up and
they're counting their money like the
guy on the monopoly box and they're
puffing cigars and they're not working
and it's really all the people who
aren't making a lot of money they're
just the ones working all the time in my
experience I've known a lot of people
who don't make a lot of money I know a
lot of people who make an okay
and I've known some people who have made
a lot of money in my experience the ones
who make a lot of money are the hardest
workers they work all the time
because there's not a lot of room at the
top and you've got to fight really hard
to get up there and they do it I think
Millennials are missing that message
saying I don't want to I don't want to
work the system is rigged against me I
if I work really I'm gonna that means
I'm gonna have to subordinate my will
that means I'm gonna not be able to
indulge in everything I want to indulge
in that means that I'm gonna have to
make a mortgage payment then I'm gonna
have to settle in a place in a town I'm
gonna have to like know people and know
my neighbors that doesn't sound fun at
all I want to do me I mean the the only
moral rule that we follow in this
culture is if it feels good do it you
see this expressed in how we treat sex
in just a hookup culture rather than a
more traditional culture if it feels
good do it you see it in how we approach
our free time what do what do people do
in their free time they play video games
and they watch porn and that is the
definition of if it feels good do it
same thing in our jobs I mean you see
this in this social survey 49 percent of
Millennials would if possible quit their
current jobs within two years why
because they're dissatisfied with pay
and they are not advancing as fast as
they would like they come in and they
want to be the boss on day one less than
three and ten Millennials expect to stay
at a current job for the next five years
because jobs aren't fun even fun jobs
aren't fun all the time
and you're told when you come from a
generation look I came from it I have a
ton of empathy this is why I am
passionate about this topic is when you
come from a generation where you get a
participation trophy and you get really
high grades even though you don't know
that much you're going to be
dissatisfied with the real professional
world I played a little league for eight
years I think I hit the ball four times
now I did lean into pitches like Don
Baylor so I had a pretty high on base
percentage but I did not hit the ball I
was not good at baseball and guess how
many baseball trophies I have eight
guess how many time
my team won anything any championship
none zero times but I have eight
trophies because they gave them to me
you'll notice in colleges now the
average GPA is much much higher than it
was in the 60s and 70s they would attack
George Bush when Bush was running for
president because he was a c' student
but he actually had higher grades than
john kerry who he was running against
and why it's because a lot of people had
c grades then now very few people get
C's because of Great Inflation now
people get a's when i was in college it
was hard to get below a b-plus you had
to really work he'd pretty much had to
punch the professor in the face to get
below a b-plus at Harvard Harvey
Mansfield who's probably the last
conservative faculty member there he
gives students two grades he gives them
the grade they deserve and then the much
higher grade for their transcript
because grade inflation is a reality so
you come out of that world where you're
told you're SuperDuper special and
everything you do is great you come into
the professional world and then most
people start out as grunts I mean I've
worked grunt jobs plenty of them and if
you've been told your whole life that
you're a winner and you're a winner and
everything you do is great and you're
better than this and you get into a job
where you just have to be a grunt
you'll be dissatisfied with that you
want to leave it within the next two to
five years same thing the percentage of
Millennials who see starting a family is
very important is now down to 39% that's
down six points from the generation oh
I'm sorry
that's down way from the generation
before us in the generation before that
the bright side is actually it's a
little bit higher for members of Gen Z
so it's not just that things are getting
progressively worse all the time it's
actually that Millennials are the most
stuck in childhood Millennials are the
most miserable in terms of the behaviors
that describe the difference between
adulthood and childhood the generation
that came right before us Gen X exhibits
them at a higher rate than Millennials
and the generation that's coming right
after us is exhibiting it at a higher
rate than men
there's just something about our
generation which especially won't grow
up I think part of this is we grew up in
the Obama era not to blame Barack Obama
for everything but talk about a
mealy-mouthed wishy-washy administration
the Obama era was hope and change we can
do anything you don't have to work
people who built things didn't build
things you didn't build that
it just happened because of the
government when Obama ran for
re-election you're the life of Julia
Julia never had to work from cradle to
grave Big Daddy Obama would give you
everything you wanted don't worry I mean
when Barack Obama passed the Affordable
Care Act and Nancy Pelosi was trying to
push Obamacare through Congress she said
it'll be so great
because right now your health insurance
is tied to your employment so you've got
to stay at your job to keep health
insurance which is very expensive but
now once we divorce health insurance
from your job you can quit your job you
can become a poet you can become an
artist that that way and now I've looked
at a lot of bad art and I've read a lot
of bad poetry in my life most people
shouldn't be artists and poets most
people should work at jobs man was made
to work but we were told during those
years work is a bad thing you shouldn't
want to work you shouldn't want to
settle down you should just get
everything for free now we're kind of
breaking out of that so I'm not
surprised that Gen Z is starting to
change its views on that but do you know
what the top concerns for Millennials
are on according to this survey if I
were a millennial and I I had read all
of this information my top concerns
would be I'm never going to accomplish
anything I'm gonna be buried in debt I'm
not gonna have a family we're gonna have
dropping birth rates I'm gonna die
lonely I would have a lot of very
serious concerns do you know what the
top concern for Millennials is global
warming they're buried in debt they have
worthless education they don't have good
jobs or good work ethic they don't have
houses they aren't settled down they're
upset and miserable all the time their
politics is full
around them and they are most worried
about the Sun monster and how in a
hundred years the global mean
temperature is going to increase 0.2
degrees according to some model
somewhere which will have some effect on
the polar bears but we don't know what
that's their top concern do you know
what their next biggest concern is
income inequality the distribution of
wealth their concern isn't their own
incomes which are low and they should
try to make them higher their concern is
income inequality they would be fine if
everybody's income were lower as long as
they were they were less unequal as long
as the rich were poorer that would be
okay not that everybody should make more
money no it's also because of a certain
entitlement imagine the entitlement that
you would have to feel to say yes my
second most important concern is that
that guy's money is in his pocket
instead of my pocket I mean it is
literally the feeling of entitlement to
somebody else's money it's like what
Bill DeBlasio said the mayor of New York
in his presidential announcement video
first line there's a lot of money in
this country it's just in the wrong
hands that's what Millennials are saying
look I haven't made a lot of money I
don't want to work very hard I don't
want to make a lot of money I don't want
to settle down but there's a lot of
money in this country it's just in the
wrong hands give me your money and then
the third biggest priority according to
Millennials terrorism crime personal
safety so the only actual threat to
these people is the third biggest
concern after global warming and after
the redistribution of wealth because
they they think that rich people are too
rich totally backwards now this will
make people miserable much more than an
economic downturn much more than
whatever outside force they're whining
about this attitude is what is going to
make you miserable that sense of
entitlement
that hysterical apocalyptic ideological
view of nature and and politics that
will make you miserable not settling
down not having close relationships not
working hard that will make you
miserable hard work I know it doesn't
seem like it all the time hard work
makes you feel good and it makes you
feel good because you have actually
accomplished something out here in
Hollywood everybody is an unemployed
actor or writer or director and they're
always once should I get a day job
should I change should I do something
else
success is a good thing if you feel
better about yourself you can provide
more for your family it's nice at a
certain point you have got to stop
blaming daddy for all of your problems
millenials are adults now we talk about
Millennials like they're still kids I'm
29 the oldest Millennials are 38 and
they're mostly unmarried and not having
kids they're not acting like adults that
is the lie I mean the lie that we have
been told is you can be a kid forever
it's it's a Neverland generation I won't
grow up I won't grow up because we think
it's nice to be a kid
oh how free and happy everything was
when we were children we didn't have any
responsibilities yeah that's nice when
you're a child but it's pathetic when
you're an adult I know you think in your
teens or early 20s you think gosh all I
want to do is go out to bars and hang
out and be single and hook up and do
whatever because all of those things are
super fun they're really fun when you're
a teenager in your 20s and they're
pathetic when you're in your 50s because
time moves on you have to mature
if you don't mature if you stagnate then
you will decay and you will become
miserable and this is in part because
Millennials have been taught awful
lessons that they have internalized and
one of those lessons came to us just the
other day at the Tulane University
commencement ceremony from Tim Cook CEO
of Apple we'll get to that in a second
but first go to Daley wire.com ten bucks
a month $100 for an annual membership
you get me you get the Andrew Klavan
show you get the bench up here
you get the Matt Walsh show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag coming up
on Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom and
you get the leftist tears
tumblr mmm that is delicious this is a
drink for a grown up this is really when
you're a little kid you drink milkshakes
when you're an adult you drink leftist
tears go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
so the millennial generation is
particularly miserable because they
won't grow up I guess that's a failure
of parenting I guess that's a failure of
our educators at a certain point it's
your own failure that you're not
engaging in those behaviors but
Millennials are continually being taught
bad lessons the generation after its Gen
Z continually being taught bad lessons
and in this case from one of the most
successful people in the world Apple CEO
Tim Cook he's got one opportunity to
give advice to graduating seniors here's
the advice he gives in some important
ways my generation has failed you in
this regard we've been too focused on
the fight and not focused enough on
progress
and you don't need to look far to find
an example of that failure when we talk
about climate change or any issue with
human cost and there are many I
challenge you to look for those who have
the most to lose and find the real true
empathy that comes from something shared
that is really what we all one another
today certain algorithms pull toward you
the things you already know believe or
like and they push away everything else
push back it shouldn't be this way in
that speech he gives completely
contradictory advice so the first thing
he says oh this is the worst thing he
said and he made at the center of his
speech he said in many ways my
generation has failed you
we focused too much on the fight and not
enough on progress and what he means is
we focus too much on open debate we
focus too much on debating our ideas in
the public forum and letting everybody
have their say and then letting the good
arguments win we focused too much on
that and not enough on progress like on
the issue of climate change what is
progress whose progress to whom what Tim
Cook is talking about is what he thinks
is progress and he said we focus too
much on letting everybody have their own
say in their own self-government and not
enough on forcing people to do exactly
what I want them to do we focus too much
on letting people debate the science of
global warming and pointing out that all
of the models that the global warming
alarmists have made haven't come true
and how the world actually won't end in
12 years we focused too much on that and
not enough on completely up ending the
economy because Alexandria cassio Court
has told us to what he's saying is
undercutting our system of government
and then not five minutes later he says
algorithms are feeding you your own
opinions and you shouldn't just get your
own opinions you should hear other
people's opinions yes that part is true
but then why did
you just tell us to stop engaging with
other people's opinions and just through
our own brute force and tyranny of will
force progressive opinions on the whole
country totally opposite thinking but
that is the message that the culture is
telling us that's the message that
Millennials have internalized we have
become much less tolerant we have become
much less capable of civil discourse
we've become much less capable of
self-government there's a new report out
from the knight foundation it shows that
41% of college students the people that
Tim Cook is talking to believe that hate
speech should not be protected by the
First Amendment
I bet Tim Cook agrees with that I know
Tim Cook agrees with that one because
Apple censors conservatives but also
because he's saying we have to stop
focusing on the fight and he's using the
word fight to mean debate this is what
the left has done broadly is they
conflate speech with violence and so
listen we use the fight in a
metaphorical way the left is now
actually conflating speech with violence
saying we focus too much on open debate
let's just focus on progress and and if
you're just gonna focus on progress then
you have to stifle debate which is what
big tech is doing it's what Apple is
doing its what 41% of colleges want to
do they want to shut up people who have
different views from them now
fortunately 58% of college students
believe that hate speech should be
protected by the First Amendment so you
have 41% say it shouldn't 58% say it
should 1% apparently too stupid to
understand the question probably
shouldn't be in college in the first
place but only 58% believe that hate
speech should be protected by the First
Amendment the only speech that is
addressed by the First Amendment is hate
speech by the way because what is hate
speech what does that term mean it means
whatever people want it to mean the left
wing calls this program hate speech the
left wing says if you're to the right of
Hillary Clinton you're engaging in hate
speech so the only reason we have to
protect speech
is because some people want to shut it
down if speech is inoffensive to
everybody you don't need to protect it
because no one cares you only have to
protect hate speech and 41% of American
college students want to gut the First
Amendment and this this is interesting
because it breaks down a little bit by
demographic groups the majority of
college women don't think hate speech
should be protected most women the
majority of black students don't believe
that hate speech should be protected the
majority of students believe that
shouting down speakers is always or
sometimes acceptable
I've been shouted down given campus
speeches a lot of other conservatives
have - a lot of the administrators of
these schools have defended that
practice but now the majority of
students at university campuses which
depend on the free exchange of ideas
think it is acceptable always or
sometimes to silence through the
hecklers veto ideas that they disagree
with or that they think that they
disagree with but they probably don't
understand them because they haven't
heard them because they shout them down
at least at least the silver lining is
that 83% of these students agree that
violence is unacceptable as a means to
ending an event that you don't like so
that's good news the bad news is 17% of
college students think that physical
violence is an acceptable way to shut
down an event that you don't like again
this varies along racial lines for some
reason 60% of black students believe
inclusivity is more important than free
speech
what does inclusivity mean I don't know
it's ironic that 60% of black students
believe that inclusivity is more
important than free speech because now
at half of the colleges in America they
have a racially segregated dorms black
only dorms so you have the majority of
black college students saying we need
inclusivity we're so focused on
inclusivity that we should trounce the
First Amendment also we should racially
segregated dorms which is the exact
opposite of inclusivity it is
segregation 49% of Hispanic students
believe inclusive 'ti is more important
than free speech 42
percent of white students believe that
inclusivity is is more important than
free speech now I don't know why this
varies along racial lines I suspect it
is the same problem that we've been
talking about you've got cynical people
cynical educators and cynical
politicians targeting specifically black
students and insisting to them that they
are victims that life isn't fair that
it's rigged against them that they can't
succeed and if you've been told that
from the time you were in the cradle to
the time that you're graduating college
if you've been told that you shouldn't
listen to other ideas if you've been
told by the CEO of Apple Tim Cook that
we shouldn't have any more debate we
should just have progress it makes
perfect sense to me that you especially
would believe that inclusion or or
progress or whatever euphemism you want
to throw in is more important than free
speech what this is leading toward all
of it is violence not just violence on
campus you know I got attacked by that
weirdo anti-fatigue Missouri Kansas City
other professors have been attacked too
there was an event with the conservative
Charles Murray at Middlebury College and
a female professor there got whiplash
because of it when Ben went to speak at
Berkeley it cost the city six hundred
thousand dollars to secure Berkeley
against a five foot nine Orthodox Jew
who is relatively mild mannered because
of the threat of violence but it's not
just on college campuses now from the
u.s. to the UK the violence has turned
on politicians so in the United Kingdom
the conservative politician Nigel Farage
who is a brexit ear he will he wants to
affect the brexit the people voted for
is being attacked with milkshakes this
is an epidemic going around the in
Britain leftists are throwing milkshakes
of politicians they don't like and so
Nigel Farage just got hit with one
yesterday and he keeps on walking by a
Tommy Robinson who is a independent
journalist he's a political activist and
he talks about questions of Islam same
thing gets attacked with a milkshake how
do you think the mainstream media are
reacting to political violence in the UK
Britain have weaponized the milk
shake and the latest in a series of
attacks on right-wing politicians brexit
party leader Nigel Farage was doused
with a milkshake yesterday that was
actually salted caramel if anyone's
wondering he was campaigning these
attacks have come to be known as milk
shaking now this follow is egging it has
pying there's punching I don't know put
some of that I know I'm sure it feels
great I'm sure people love the feeling
and the pictures fly around the world
put some of that energy energy into
campaigning yeah maybe the people you
don't want to be in office won't be in
office and maybe just drink the
milkshake police are actually asking
places to not sell milkshake I was
really ears daddy yes around Edden broke
the suppose are they they actually asked
places around was a political appearance
not to sell milkshake I'm sure it feels
great I think it was salted caramel
hahaha look at that look at that Nigel
Farraj Burger King made a joke about
this they tweeted out that they were
going to give out free milkshakes so
that people could throw them at
politicians and I get it it's milkshakes
are funny and if you don't like a
certain politician isn't it's funny to
throw something on him oh come on it's
not a big deal it's a milkshake oh come
on Michael the weird chemicals that they
threw on you at the University of
missouri-kansas city
they weren't toxic it wasn't ammonia it
didn't bleach your skin it's not a big
deal okay I'm sure look we're all big
boys me and Farraj and Tommy Robinson we
can ruin a suit I guess I mean it's I
don't like buying new suits but that's
fine we can take a milkshake or we can
take a squirt of some weird perfumes but
the principle that is being established
here by the left and being laughed at by
the mainstream media and by corporate
America is that it's okay to throw
things at politicians so guess what
happens not a week after these protests
started someone decided to up the ante
and throw a brick at Tommy Robinson
brick that's a little little tougher
than a milkshake isn't it I mean this is
what we said when it happened at
University of Missouri so okay it's I
mean I'm glad it was a non toxic
chemical that they squirted on me just
as easily could have been a toxic
chemical just as easily could have been
something else out of a different kind
of gun just as easily could have been a
brick and this is being laughed at this
is being encouraged there is a a break a
fundamental breakdown of polite society
of civil society I mean this this
estimate that came
the schools of on the segregated dorms
at least 75 American colleges have black
only graduation ceremonies and 43
percent of colleges surveyed have blacks
only residential halls segregated
residential halls a breakdown of civil
society the opposite of inclusion and in
this in this era 4 in 10 Americans
embrace socialism 43 percent of
Americans not just Millennials Americans
overall as Millennials become a bigger
proportion of the voting population 43
percent say socialism is a good thing
that's up from 25 percent in 1942 this
is all happening you know as Ernest
Hemingway said bankruptcy happens
gradually then suddenly left ISM happens
gradually then suddenly we're seeing it
happen suddenly now you're saying with
the up ending of our political system
the embrace of socialism some people are
trying to fight back President Trump
very clearly trying to fight back
America was founded on liberty and
independence and not government coercion
domination and control we are born free
and we will stay free
tonight we renew our resolve that
America will never be a socialist
country so President Trump said this
during his last State of the Union and
this was a great line we all cheered and
some people said well maybe it could be
I mean a OSE wants it to be Bernie wants
it to be what he said is literally right
though
America will never cease we'll never be
a socialistic country because if America
became a socialist country it would
cease to be American America would be
unrecognizable as a socialist country
America is the opposite of a socialist
country and yet people want to totally
invert what America is and make it into
the opposite of America this radicalism
is making everyone miserable I mean does
it measurably clinically making people
miserable from the gender issue to the
education issue to to the civil society
to the institutions to the way that we
interact with each other to the way we
communicate to the way that we conduct
our politics it's making people
miserable and so what is the left insist
on more radicalism this is the left they
have the such a knack for this they you
know institute a government program
government program that creates a lot of
problems look at the Great Society
President Johnson's welfare program so
all of this welfare spending it's aimed
specifically at poor black Americans but
other people as well and what happens in
the Moynihan report you look at it 20
years later it turns out those
government programs hurt the very people
they were intended to help they ensnared
people in cycles of poverty increased
rates of crime increased rates of
divorce increased rates of out of
wedlock birth lower marriage rates
higher poverty higher crime and so what
does the Left come in and say they say
wow that's a big problem I guess we need
more government government creates the
problem and then the left tells us we
need more government to fix the problem
radicalism creates the misery then the
left tells us we need more radicalism to
fix the misery the same principles
apply to the culture feminism is making
women miserable that we we can measure
this from the 1970s to the present since
the rise of second wave feminism to the
present women have become less happy
both in relative terms to men and in
absolute terms feminism is making women
miserable and so what do the feminists
tell us yeah we need more feminism the
reason it's making women miserable is
because we don't have enough feminism we
have a wage gap which is completely
mythical we don't have perfect equality
we need more feminism to fix the problem
caused by feminism the sexual revolution
making people miserable
making people lonely so what is the sex
revolution types what do they tell us we
need more sexual revolution we need to
shout your abortion
we don't need abortion to be safe legal
and rare we need more of it we need more
pornography we need more hookup culture
we need a less stable relationships and
yet we keep being told there was a piece
just came out in the New York Times I'm
sure they choked this one down they
didn't want to publish it turns out
guess who the happiest of all wives are
in America the left would tell you it's
single Democrat women living in the city
working at a non-profit probably right
or like working in some coffee shop or
something no this is what the New York
Times reports broken clock right twice a
day quote it turns out that the happiest
of all wives in America are religious
conservatives followed by their
religious progressive counterparts fully
73 percent of wives who hold
conservative gender values and attend
religious services regularly with their
husbands have high quality marriages the
most conservative the most traditional
people are the happiest another survey
just came out this survey is a doozy it
showed that President Trump has made
America less racist make America great
again has made America less racist we've
been told for three years
New York The New Yorker wrote quote hate
on rise since Trump Time magazine wrote
racist incidents up since Donald Trump's
election the nation wrote Donald Trump's
rise has coincided with an explosion in
hate groups except now there's a new
survey out from the University of
Pennsylvania it shows that Americans
quote have actually become lesson
mind to express racist opinions since
Donald Trump was elected anti-black
prejudice they found declined by a
statistically insignificant degree
between 2012 and 2016 so during the
Obama years racism and anti-black
prejudice did not really decline did not
measurably decline but then after 2016
it took a sharp dive that was
statistically significant contrary to
their expectations the full was as
evident among Republican voters as it
was among Democrats progressive
radicalism gave us racial bigotry make
America great again
stark decline in racial bigotry people
who have traditional marriages very
happy people who don't not happy this
tells us something about radicalism and
tradition when I talk about conservatism
I'm talking about tradition traditional
marriages traditional American
institutions making America great again
traditional American views on hard work
and achieving something and loving your
neighbors the Left views tradition as an
irrational madness to be replaced the
tradition it's not a it's not a
manifesto it's not a Dogma it's not a an
argument like the left is making it's
not an ideology the right recognizes the
brilliance of tradition when I say
tradition I'm talking about just things
that have stuck around a long time
because what the right realizes that is
that if lots and lots of people have
done a certain thing for a very very
long time all over the world all over
our civilization maybe they knew
something that I don't know maybe they
were onto something that the social
engineers who concocted a new
institution or a new definition of
marriage or a new definition of the
economy or a new definition of gender
roles it didn't know have bet on
marriage you know Gloria Steinem told us
a woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle during the sex revolution well
if that's true then how come virtually
everyone everywhere has gotten married
forever
maybe there's some wisdom in that
tradition I think people are waking up
to it
but one generation has been really
really affected by this radicalism
that's the Millennials if they want to
have a good life they're gonna have to
wake up to it fast because time is
running out as all of us are not kids
anymore we're not living in Neverland as
much as we might think we are that's our
show get your mailbag questions and for
Thursday in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael an old show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua Alvaro and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey everyone
its Andrew Klavan hosted the Andrew
Clavin show you know if it weren't for
the fact that the Democrats owned the
news and entertainment media would be
obvious by now that they are living in a
blithering fantasy world Donald Trump is
a racist except who's erases too he's a
dictator except what does he dictates
all 'us but what laws has he broken they
have invented a Donald Trump of the
imagination and he ain't the real Donald
Trump at all we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin